thomas wolfe is our very own co-founder
and chief science officer at urging face
and top of creating many popular
libraries like transformers and data
sets he is also the initiators and
senior chair of the largest research
collaboration that has ever existed in
artificial intelligence called big
science
and today you will talk to us about
transfer learning and the birth of the
transformers library
so then ready when you are
thanks a lot siva
okay hi everyone and today i'm very
happy to make a talk a little bit
different than what i do usually
um since you will learn a lot of things
in the in the coming course right this
is the this is a
full week of classes a full week of
chapters to read so i thought i won't do
an educational course like i do usually
but i'll actually talk about the origin
of hacking phase and the origin of
transformers the origin of
our library and kind of walks you
through
a very personal uh honestly selection of
what happened in the past few years
attacking phase and in the field of
transfer learning
so let's go back uh in time
uh to the very beginning of why we're
here today at least why i'm here today
which is uh four years ago five years
ago now
october 4
who was an old classmate of of me we
were making we were playing music
together in a kind of progressive rock
band
um
kind of talk to me about the coming
revolution of deep learning and and say
okay you you've been doing a little bit
of science at uh before before doing
your
your law degree
and you want to come back to doing so
science and i was like yeah actually
yeah and so we follow together
and this stand for
cs224d deep learning for nlp class which
was a lot about a lot about lstm
uh skip thought vectors for those who
were already following a little bit
and actually this is i think interesting
because today we came back to this right
we're doing a course at that time also
we followed that over the internet there
was still no pandemic it was easier but
still the course was at stanford we were
both in europe
and so maybe today some of you will be
following this class
with friends maybe friends in the music
globe band or i don't know
and maybe in a few years we'll have a
very successful startup that started
today starting this week by following
this course together and that's really
all that i hope for you i think for us
it's been an amazing and amazing
journey from this uh from this day to
today
and um the early days of hugging face
were actually quite different than the
haggy face we know today
we were building a
an ai chatbot
that
was a little bit like atomic talking
tamagotchi
you could uh you could like discuss with
it it was at the beginning of generative
technologies right or with lstm
um
and you could also send it selfie there
was beginning of image classification to
try to understand a little bit what you
were sending and to try to reply with
something fun and that's how hacking
face started we were just three four at
this time
um but quite quickly we actually started
to open source a little bit of of code
so this is um
this is a screenshot from the hugging
face github pages
four years ago
you can see probably libraries and
framework you don't know because they've
changed a lot but it was the first one
we were really proud of our core friends
charts adaptation of an emoji detector
offer like sentimental detector
but uh why has this all completely
changed
because there was a couple of
revolutions in the field of nlp
a few years after we started so more
precisely
around the beginning of 2018 i would say
so i think if you want to date back this
could maybe go back to this first
unsupervised sentiment neuron
paper from from alex radford already at
open ai where they trained an lstm
on
the largest data center that people
had at the time which was data set of
amazon reviews
well actually the internet was already
there but still not a common practice
right to use that as a training data set
so they trained this lstm and what they
discovered is that
the the model the lstm learned to
actually categorize to categorize
sentiment
without being explicitly taught to do
that so this was trained in a generative
fashion this lstm was trained to
generate the next token just like we do
today right
um and they they also identified well
something that we don't really use
anymore today i would say but some
specific neurons
that were very uh finely tuned to detect
sentiment
and so this was the first
um this was the first hint that
unsupervised free training with a
generative objective could lead to good
performances on downstream tasks like
sentiment classification but this was
still uh using uh
lstm and the set was still quite i would
say domain specific amazon reviews are
still not i would say as widely
um
as covering a wide field of nlp as the
let's say that we have today
a bit later uh i'll stay at the end of
2017.
so a few months later were were there
the first uh i think most impactful
paper which was this first elmo which is
uh the the first um this this paper
called deep contextualized
representation there was the l mode in
the beginning of the
of the muppet names right for for all
this model which kind of showed that if
you pre-trained on kind of a
an lstm on a wide a wider diversity of
text so this one was unfortunately using
a shuffle task so it only had like full
sentence but not full paragraph
you could actually have good
performances on a lot of nlp tasks and
not only sentiment analysis but also
like question answering textual
entailments and this kind of thing the
idea here was still kind of to extract
um token representation
more than maybe what we do today with
like full pre-trained model
and then really concurrent to this work
was the very nice ulm feet from
sebastian reader and jeremy howard
where they also pre-trained this lstm
and they also show that you could adapt
it to many many tasks
so these two papers really at the same
time at the beginning of 2018 people
were like oh
maybe all this approach of transfer
learning that we've been using computer
vision on imagenet for a long time could
be useful also in text
and so this kind of led sebastian to
wrote this this interesting piece in
around summer 2018
which was uh maybe the imagenet moment
of nlp has arrived right and he was very
uh i think insightful in saying oh
pre-trained language model can achieve
state-of-the-art results and that's
something that's going to change
everything
but this was just one part of the
revolution which is transfer learning
pre-trained model
and the second part
was using transformers in place from
from
lstm
and here again uh i think alec radford
from open eye was really uh was really
pioneering this by using the the gpt the
first gpt in 2018 so this was around the
summer
with this generative pre-trained
transformers
and actually the name really gpt was i
think only coined in the following bird
paper from google which was a few months
later in october 8 2018 where i kind of
used this same transformer model but
instead of using it
as a causal or auto aggressive model
they used the now famous uh masked
language modeling objective right
denoising or genoising objectives and so
these two papers were very interesting
because they mixed this early idea of
transfer learning
like having a model pre-trained
on a large data set with the
architectural improvement of the
transformer which made mostly
the
the training very efficient a lot more
efficient than lstm so today we we have
like other well maybe we're coming back
i'm not sure this is maybe what you will
be charged to do if you do research in
this film
and uh what was the conclusion of mixing
these two objectives well it was really
a storm in the nlp field so you can see
this if you go for instance on paper
with code if you check this curve
showing the the state of the art at
various time what you see is that in
around the end of 2017 beginning of 2018
you see this very strong slope upward
right there was like performance was
basically plateauing for like years
right here we see that on ner
since basically 2009
we did not really move up anything and
then from like summer 2018 17 tagalog
was already kind of a first transfer
learning approach actually and then with
transformer we were moving upward very
strongly squad 2 you see also the same
very
strong increase in the performance of
the model
by using bert you see the jump bird
single model there's a very strong jump
10 points
in exact match here matrix
and then well you can say maybe we're
plating again today i think most of the
the reason we're platting is that square
two is now kind of saturated actually as
a benchmark
and so we were following that very
closely uh and basically when gpt the
first of the names so this one
went out we were actually uh at
hagneyface participating in a challenge
at at new eurips
well this is an old slide so we still
call it nips but that's that's not
europe's right 2018 we are participating
in this conversation ai challenge so the
goal was um
when you have a
some sort of chatbot
you had to like uh take into account a
little persona for your robot and you
have to answer it in a in a convincing
way to a user so it's a little bit like
a turing test right but you have a
personal you you're supposed to pretend
you're you're this person here and this
uh challenge was interesting because it
came with a nice
data set made by by the new york new
york facebook team and um for this first
time gpt was just out and we were like
okay maybe let's try this gpt let's try
this pre-training approach for for
generative tasks as well a lot of people
were just using this model for
classification task and so we tried for
the first time to use it for really
purely generative tasks like chatbots
and the results you can see on the right
were really impressive we were directly
on top of the leaderboard of competition
and by very strong margin the perplexity
the first column you know like
perplexity is is a kind of an
exponential matrix so it's quite hard to
divide by two the perplexity but we were
like
two times slower than the other than the
other model well this matrix well if you
if you've done a little bit of
generative
nlp and you will learn that in the
course here it's very hard to evaluate
so this did not translate always in
human evaluation but it was still
already very very very impressive
and when we studied a little bit and
compared to the other
teams what we saw is that
if something were very good on the
validation set
they often go went very down on the
hidden test set so if you've been doing
a little bit of kaggle you know that
this mostly means that you're starting
to overfit on the validation probably
the public data set
and some team were a bit lower and
staying lower right which is more like a
sign of kind of underfitting if you want
and what we saw is that our approach was
both using transfer learning
and transformer as well the transfer
learning i think is the strongest
ingredient
um using transfer learning we were both
very strong validation sets and we
stayed very robust on the on the test
set
and so this led us
in the next summer in june june 2019 to
do a very long tutorial around transfer
learning in nlp with a few a few friends
sebastian reader matthew peters who
basically created this this field swaba
who also actually did really great stuff
i won't show here but you should check
them out
and what we saw there well what we tried
to do there is try to explain a little
bit what was the ide and so just as an
insight you will learn more in the
course but basically this is the like
the secret ingredient of transfer
learning
is that
in traditional machine learning we had
all these separate tasks this is on the
left you had task 1 you wanted to do any
r you had a data set for ner and you
basically randomly initialize your model
and train it from scratch on this data
set if you are now trying to do
summarization of chatbots you will
gather another data set of summarization
or chat bots and you will again just
create a machine learning system
specialized for this task and if you had
another task again
same thing you will have very separate
pipelines so very separate uh systems
were already well under
each time trains from scratch and the
approach of transfer learning was to do
a little bit more like i would say human
do which is that we don't
randomly initialize our brain each time
we tackle a new task right what we do is
that we use all the knowledge that we've
learned in the class in our life
experiences to bootstrap our learning
right and so when we have a new task we
just reuse all this knowledge that we
have and this gives us mostly two main
advantages that we see also when we when
we produce that with with machine
learning models which is first that we
are very data efficient
because we can fill the gaps between all
the examples that people are giving of a
new task
and so we are very data efficient and we
usually reach better performances and
this is also related because we can fill
the gap
between all the
between the data examples that we have
on the on the new target task
we can reach better performances and
transfer learning is a way to try to do
the same for for machine learning so to
try to build this kind of generic
knowledge that can be reused on many
many tasks
so we have
we have questions that could go here tom
it's it's very systematic way to
estimate how many annotated samples to
train to fine-tune an existing model for
instance on a
on an air task
yeah that's a good question
um
it's quite different it's quite
dependent uh so
really the the direction the field is
trying to go is the world few what we
call few shots so using less and less
example so i mean requiring less and
less examples
so for some tasks that you will see in
the course
you can actually do zero shots like tech
classification you actually in many
cases don't need any example
but then it's it's always very dependent
on how specific your domain is and
typically the more specific your domain
is the more you will need example and in
some cases you might be you might still
be outside of the pre-training domain of
the model where you and then you will
need quite a large data set
yeah thanks
and so um yeah let's go yeah
why would this work in nlp where you
probably have the intuition but here
they are the idea is that
many nlp tasks if you look them from if
you like take a step back they share
common knowledge about language they
share that oops
in full screen yeah
basically if you if you know for
instance um
adjectives if you know linguistics uh
then it will help you a lot for instance
if you want to do any r right you want
to identify i don't know the name of
organization
if your model already if your model
already have a good knowledge about
linguistics and know what is a noun
that would help it a lot because it will
know that name of organization are very
likely nouns okay they are not
adjectives they are not verbs so only
thing can be useful for the model
the same right if your task is in
english if your model know a little bit
about english you can just learn
basically the missing pieces that it has
on your task and don't and won't spend
like
won't need i would say like half of your
uh training that i said just to learn
how english works in general right
so tasks can also inform each other
typically as i told you syntax and
semantics they are often related if
something is a noun that's also mean
that is as it has a meaning related to
to noun if it's an adjective that's here
to kind of change the meaning of a noun
so holy thing
um
obviously annotated data data you know
that is rare it's very difficult so the
more we can gather it the more we can
gather several data sets together to
build a bigger one the better it is for
our model we know that these neural
network models they are still data
hungry right we don't we don't have a
lot of feature that's the nice thing
about them but the control the the
counterpart is that they are data angry
because they will need to learn this
feature themselves
and now the most i would say a down on
earth reason why it works is that when
we try it works so that's currently the
state of the art for many many nlp tasks
it's to use this transfer learning so
that's also a good reason to think that
well maybe it has reason to work
so i talk a lot about science here like
transfer learning revolution is is a
scientific revolution in the field but
uh if you're here today it's also
because you you've probably following
our hope open source work and this was
kind of
started in parallel to that we always
thought that open source and open
science were going hand in hand and so
very early we started to open source
some models so the first one we did is
here it's now uh
the summer of 2018. so just before
basically this this transfer learning
refuge revolution really really begun
and so we we did this neural
coefficients which was a conference
model for spacey
which already saw very interesting very
interesting uh performances for for uh
also a pre-trained actually neural
network but only for correference
and then there was obviously this gpt so
i told you we were using the first
version of gpt in this first competition
and that's where basically we understood
that wow this was very powerful
and before before using it as always we
actually released an open source version
so actually a bit later we discovered
that some other competitors also used
our open source gpt in the same
competition
so it was very very interesting we
actually made a paper together
at acl the a year later
so it's a bit the open source way of
hugging face always trying to do
something collaboratively for everyone i
think that uh we we can just get this
the sum of every open source thing is is
larger than the
having just everything private models
and these two these two early effort and
the interest we saw from people
led us to try to do that uh again and
this led us to first um the first uh
stone of transformers which was this
conversion of birds in pythor so in
october there was this bird model from
google and people are like wow this this
is really an impressive model
and so when the code was open source in
tensorflow one at the time we thought oh
that's a little bit of shame because uh
tensorflow one is still a little bit
difficult to use right and there was uh
pydosh already at that time
it was pytorch version 0.3 but it was
still quite interesting and easy to use
and so we decided okay let's convert
this tensorflow model in python let's
see if people will be uh we will be able
to use it easier right
and our idea here was basically that
well first at that time
birds sounded like a very large model it
was 300 million
parameters which today sounds like maybe
the smallest model that you that you use
at least in a research field
but at that time it was like really
really large and so like
nobody will be able to train that so we
should make it easy to use the
pre-trained weights that that google are
really nicely released
and to make it the easiest we should
actually have them also in pareto
and so that's what we did
and that's that lead to this first uh
version called pytorch pre-trained bird
and this was really very far from
transformers uh but we had a few initial
id that evolved so one initial idea was
that we could also host the train
weights on our s3 buckets so that people
didn't have to to to go through the the
painful process of downloading and
converting them and we could maybe just
load them and here we were inspired by
by joel gurusnay
nicely
nicely made from free tray method in
lnlp which which i found very very nice
with just one one line of python you
could download a pre-trained model in
ln nlp and so i was like okay let's
actually use the same id
and so this was the first thing uh and
this evolved over the coming
two years i would say from 2018 to 2020
to a fully fledged git version model hub
that you will see today which both i
think give you very uh
wide access to the model it's very easy
to inspect and to inspect it and at the
same time give you a lot of interesting
like widget to play with the model
online api to use it very easily so all
this you will see in the class but
that's very interesting
and the first idea was also just to give
access to birds right but then i was
like okay we actually have an open
source code for gpt and also for bert
why not to actually make them in a
single library
and this led us very quickly to
basically a single api which today i
think grew up not far from 100 different
architectures
which is the the today transformers and
so this the first version was python
transformers with with four
architectures
and quickly we thought
now tensorflow one is a little bit hard
to use but tensorflow 2 is quite nicely
done actually and so you're like maybe
maybe we could have both python
tensorflow 2 in the same framework maybe
we could even make it this so if you
want to use tpu to train your model on
tpu because you have like free free
access you should and then if you want
to fine-tune the same model in python
you should be able to switch very easily
from one to the other
and so we tried to make this these three
main these two main framework at that
time and then then later jackson flags
which are more more recent in the same
framework and we saw that it was
actually not not so difficult to get
them all together
and to get what is now uh transformers
right not not anymore python transformer
well biotours is still i think um maybe
the better supported one but tensorflow
and jacks are very very strongly
improving
um and so this was a transformer and
what we witness
is this basically explosion in the
number of architecture on model uh most
of them are today in transformers
because it's very easy to add new one
and so you can see from birds there are
a lot of following work trying to
experiment with
variants in the architecture i think
maybe excellent is a good example where
they try to do both some auto-aggressive
but also bi-directional way to do um
to
to do a forward pass in the neural
network
and one question became um
what is important from all for all this
model i mean how do they compare right
how do you select the model
which one do you know you want to use
and here i think what's what became also
quite clear in in the subs in the
subsequent year was that actually modern
architecture it was actually the data
that mattered a lot so i talk about
excel net which was very interesting as
a different architecture and actually
got a lot better performances than bert
at the time and people like wow we
should experiment with various
architectures for
modifying the transformers and
this subsequent work from facebook
called roberta actually showed that um
it's not so much the architecture but
just the data excellent was actually
trained on a lot more data than bert and
that's actually what matter more than
the architecture and so roberta took
very basic transformers
just exactly the same as bert and then
just trained it on more data and they
got state-of-the-art results
and this was then shown in the these two
other graphs which are from the neural
scaling paper and they show that
basically the
the architecture was the the performance
were really weakly sensitive to the
architecture so you see at the top you
see this very flat curve for feet for a
forward ratio it is very flat curve for
aspect ratio
and these are all logarithmic curves so
they actually span very large um
aspect ratio
and basically as long as you stay not
too far from the middle you're pretty
good the architecture just don't really
matter that much and the t5 paper who
came who came out later also confirmed
this basically the early transformer
paper were already very close to the
optimal architecture
but what's very important is this that
is this uh graph on the lower left where
you see the data set size this is also
from you from the neural scanning paper
from on the player from open ai and you
see that just by increasing the data set
size you have this very predictable
increase in performances so here this is
the test loss so lower is better
and this actually brought us to this
question well actually modern
architecture what is important here is
data
and so the year a year later 2002
actually or maybe year 2019
we decided to do a new library around
data we were like okay we also need to
focus on data now
and so this new library was called data
sets where early name was nlp but the
for for a long time now the name is that
set
and this library also got some quite
strong interests
from the community it passed 10k stars
well i don't know how how github stars
are relevant as a measure of interest
but it's also widely used by
by a lot of follow-up work so i think
it's very nice
and this library the idea was
date access to data is also very
difficult today in nlp mostly because
the situation is very fragmented if you
want to use a data set you typically
need to find where is the code somewhere
on github you need also to pre-process
it and you actually spend a lot of time
doing the same work to pre-process the
data set a lot of people are just
writing their csv or json loader so
maybe we could share this work and avoid
this and just jump to the data structure
that was one note
another one was that also with this very
large language model we're using now
terabytes of data and this this can be
very difficult to handle on your at
least on your personal laptop right if
you want to train a model on one
terabyte of data like roberta this is
really a pain because you typically
can't load that in ram you need to find
a smart way to do like
just loading the the current batch or
prefetching and so we thought maybe we
should solve all these issues at the
same time and the idea was that that
asset could be a way to kind of
centralize access to
to nlp data set to the beginning now
it's expanded to speech and images but
at the beginning it was really about nlp
data set
and also to cover more languages right
nlp
english i mean is really
the dominant language in research but in
production today it's not dominant
language right we have a lot of other
well it's i mean it's still the dominant
language but we have a lot of other
languages that are that are very
important and every time you're you're
actually an nlp
person working in another
country than the u.s or uk basically you
want to or india you want to work with
other languages
and so this led us to developing data
set around this effort so at the end of
november uh well one year ago now
november 2020 we did a first community
event where we said to the community
uh well with 15 people attacking phase
trying to add data set if you want you
can join this is going to be fun we're
going to do
this together you will be on our slack
we'll talk a little bit um
and also we'll do some swag and
everything and this was usually paul ug
popular actually we had i think about
300 people joining to help us we were
definitely
a little bit overwhelmed by the success
of this fur community effort
but it was very nice also in terms of
adding data set in many many languages
and the idea is that all these datasets
were then very easy to access and this
could foster more research on
multilinguality i think
and so um
this led us also to write a paper
with the whole team and also there are
there are also some community members
actually in this paper
uh you see uh gunjan um
they are both like community contributor
and to submit it today this year to mnlp
where i just actually want the best
demonstration paper so i think this is
very typical hugging face thing where we
do something very open source
uh we do that with the community at
least we we invite everyone to join if
they want to participate and then we
also do that as a science effort and
this all just go together to make
something very impactful
and so there is today also this hub that
you will see in the in the course where
you today we have about well not so far
from 2000 data sets openly accessible
you can even explore them on the hub
and so this was the 2020 effort around
data data
and what happened in 2021 um that was
open science more and big science well
what happened i would say it's very
personal walkthrough so i would mean uh
what i actually spent a lot of my time
on
was this big science effort and here the
idea was that
um
maybe it's time to do very large
collaboration in research in nlp and the
example well i'm a physics phd formally
and so i in physics when we have like
very expensive things we actually
gather as a lot of like research lab and
try to build them together and one good
example is the large hadron collider
which is in europe which is very very
large particle physics research tool it
costs i think 10 billion to build and it
has involved really a huge research
community and it has led to a lot of
research work like you have about three
thousand papers uh this led to the
discovery of many hard rounds and things
like that and so the idea was maybe it's
time to do that in ai and nlp and so
maybe why i mean why why would it be if
you die to do to do something like that
well again i think um
because uh
there was some
if you follow what i've been uh saying
up to now right there is this idea that
larger and larger data sets are
something interesting so some direction
we want to go
um this was proved again by the gbt3
paper
that showed that if you scale again the
number of tokens here you see it in
green
on the corpus side and this is again a
logarithmic scale so the scaling is
really like uh
how much is it
six order frankie no two ogre two orders
magnitude the bigger than gpt2 well if
you scale both the core precise on the
parameter size you see like very
interesting new effects and this effects
are few shots so um recently uh i mean
just have been enough to talk some
somebody asked how many how many
examples would you need and here in this
few shot example you can see that we
want to we just need like 10 examples to
get very strong performances so i don't
remember exactly what this curve was in
terms of accuracy maybe i think it was a
classification task but this one this
one is just extracted from the gpt3
paper so you can find it back and they
have a lot of course similar to this
they have a lot of curves similar to
this
and so there was this idea if you scale
this a lot you get some interesting new
effects
and then quickly what you saw is that
there are new there were a lot of
announcement of reproduction another
labs train a gpt 3-like model for korean
entropic startup of the bay area raised
a lot of money to train similar model ai
21 also trained a massive model called i
think jurassic
and another company called coher also
raised a lot of money to train all this
model and eluter was also this this
grassroot collective who trying to
reproduce so a lot of people were trying
to reproducing this
but uh for the diversity of reason we
were not super convinced about this
mostly because like all this private
company did not seem to be
targeting like open source release
and uh and uh eliter was the only one
but there was still some main problems
so here is a few issues i see well first
all this model they are not designers
research tool they're really designed by
a company to be like private thing that
they want to use for their private
products but they are not designed as
research thing so it's very typically
it's very difficult for academic
researcher to be involved in in the
development of these models right
and typically what you when you look at
the teams who build them they're like
yeah they're like small smaller than
they should be in my opinion mostly
because they just belong to one one
company and mostly
there is as again a lot of environmental
costs to training all this model in
parallel if they were open source we
wouldn't need to retrain them like in in
60 company we could just share one and
that would be a nice model for doing all
our experiments
um and there were some ethical and and
social issues mostly since the very
um beginning of gpt there there's been a
stream of paper investigating okay how
are this very large test copra and we
saw that they were lacking some
something for instance they were lacking
representativeness of of some population
um there also some typically have some
stereotypes so basically it's very hard
to investigate this training data set
also because they are typically not open
sourced
and so this calls in my opinion for like
almost a more open
and collaborative way to develop this
and this is actually possible because if
you look in
public uh you see that they are super
computer that are very powerful and
they're actually
almost fully accessible i mean you just
need to submit
like a grant an application to say i
need some compute times on this
and they have like almost
2700 v 100 gpu so that's quite a lot of
compute power you can train a very large
language model of that
so early this year i start to talk with
the
operator and builder of uh of zhanzel
which is one supercomputer located in
france that we knew a little bit from
earlier
and they say yeah i mean come come train
your model basically on our super
computer we're very happy so we we kind
of discuss a little bit internally and
then we decided that we should actually
invite everyone to come join uh and to
train this model with us and in
particular invite the academic community
which was typically outside of all these
model creations and so we filed a grant
application for enough compute time to
train a very large language model and
this was the beginning of big science
and big science has been going on for
like six months a little bit more now
nine months and it has already produced
very interesting papers so if you've
been following a hugging face account
you probably saw the the t0 paper which
involved actually uh 40 alterers um so
some of them are from hugging face but a
lot of them are not from huggy face some
are from
yeah many university um
and so this type of
papers i think is very interesting
because it's outside of the box so it's
fully open it's fully collaborative and
it's also show that you can outperform
typically gpt3 on the zero shot
benchmark with a model which is 16 times
smaller so now what we are trying to do
is to actually increase the size to 16
times larger so that's what that's what
will begin roughly next january and to
train this uh very large model on jose
to see if we how far we can go right
with the same idea of like openness open
sharing and collaborative effort
and so
what's next for 2022 at hugging phase
well there is obviously education if we
want to have a beneficial impact we
think that this is the way to start when
we talk about bias in data set when we
thought about understanding your model
knowing what is important for your model
basically we think that we should share
all the knowledge we have there is this
strong community
you're all here today i'm very happy
about that to because you've basically
if you're following more or less what
we've been doing
open source this is our dna and open
science they go hand in hand for me
sharing knowledge we try to keep
fighting for beneficial responsible ai i
talk a little bit about data set this is
very important i think to understand the
bias to understand the bias of your
model as well
and basically try to make this yeah an
inclusive place right
and while doing all that doing also this
exciting research when i say we scale
this this new model to very large uh
sizes we also try to have some fun and
not taking us too seriously uh which i
think is also um
uh
a specificity of hugging face and why
maybe we have this hugging face emoji i
would say as the name of company
so welcome to this course i'm very happy
very excited about this this second
chapter i think it's it's very
interesting you will learn a lot
and thank you for being here today
thanks a lot um um we have a few
questions i've waited for the end
because they are very general and not
directly related to what you are talking
about
one is
you talked about
a lot about transformers but what about
using graph neural networks in lp tasks
graph structures could capture data with
complex structures and relationships and
gnn provides an opportunity to study on
model complex data representation for
nlp tasks
yeah that's a good question i mean in
all generality you could consider
transformer as as a sort of graph neural
network
it's not sparse though it's fully
connected so maybe it could be more
efficient but if you look at uh like a
transformer with past attention in my
opinion it's really close to it's really
close to some graph neural network
in particular if you use if you use
weight sharing like universal
transformers
um i think in nlp transformer i kind of
dominate today
but yeah as i told you in my opinion the
main aspect of the revolution is about
transfer learning
more than the specific architecture so
if tomorrow there is a more efficient
architecture than transformer
then i would be happy to
follow follow the the work there and
basically uh switch to that
i think yeah
another question we had uh was
more about
the urging face
ecosystem
because this is infested becoming
commercial from open source
there are many parts of api that are not
paid model training for instance we go
to nlp please help me understand the
portion of open source versus paid
oh yeah
yeah so so it's still um
i mean the idea of face is i
think somehow very very typical like
open core model so everything is open
source but you need to do the training
yourself you need to do the training
group yourself so we do provide examples
uh that's actually silva has been doing
a lot of work on the examples
to to have like um
an efficient training so you have open
source code to to train this
and then we also provide some paid
solutions which are mostly there i would
say to facilitate
your work so typically if you're in a
company you don't want to wait you don't
you don't have time to actually explore
everything yourself you want some some
help then we then we also have here to
help
and then we have some specific solution
around making this model very fast
and these are typically mostly
interesting to to companies more than
researchers
because they try to lower the latency
strongly
and then here this also yeah paid
product because people who are
interested in them are typically
companies who can pay for them so the
idea is that if you're new if you're
like new to the to the field if you're a
hobbyist if you're a researcher you can
use all of this for free and then if you
have some like specific needs like you
need to go very fast to put that in
production you need to have like very
low latency because you have huge bands
within production then we also here to
help but then we we help with our with
our like additional services
that make sense
another question you hinted a little bit
about that at the end but a more fun
question is how did the name acting face
and the use come about
yeah this came from our very early
inception as a game company right we
were doing
this kind of uh talking chat bot it was
mainly for for millionaires for kids or
young adults so we wanted a fun name
we also thought it would be fun if at
some point we became a very big company
i don't know if we if we do that one day
but if we like ipo and then we have an
emoji instead of like this very serious
name that everybody has we thought yeah
let's keep this emoji
um
and i think now it's part of the fun we
like a lot of people are taking
themselves sometimes a bit too seriously
i think in the air world so we need to
say yeah this is uh this is important
but having fun is also important
and the last fun question that people
were interested in is more personal
what do you use to build trained models
notebooks vs code vim over
yeah i typically use a vs code
notebook i'm always lost in the order of
the sales
but maybe have a
bad workflow now i typically use
notebook to explore data i think it's
very very nicely done for that that's
the best way to to explore data and then
when i when i train i typically want
something which is very reproducible so
i switch to something where i can get
version cleanly and then more like
typical ps code yeah
nice
thanks a lot for your talk it was very
very interesting
and